Sie sind laut WHO eine globale Bedrohung: Impfgegner.
In Zeiten der Corona-Pandemie erhalten sie
Auftrieb. Ihre Angst: Nicht das gefährliche
Virus. Sondern eine Impfpflicht.
– Ich bin nicht dafür, dass ich meinen Körper impfen muss, wenn ich für diese Impfung keinen Sinn sehe.
Dabei gibt es In Deutschland gar keine Impfpflicht,
es sei denn Kinder besuchen eine Kita oder
Schule. Dann müssen die Eltern nachweisen,
dass ihre Kinder gegen Masern geimpft sind.
Dagegen mobilisieren die Impfgegner.
Wir begeben uns mitten unter sie.
Mit falschem Namen und erfundenen Kind – und
finden so heraus, wie Ärzte helfen, die Impf-Nachweispflicht
zu umgehen.
Und damit uns alle gefährden.
Anfang Mai auf einer Demo von Impfgegner in
Stuttgart. Viele Teilnehmer*innen warnen vor
einer Impfpflicht gegen Corona - obwohl es
noch nicht mal einen Impfstoff gibt.
– Weil, wir haben ein gutes, starkes Immunsystem.
Wenn wir das nicht hätten, wären wir schon lange alle tot.
Manche Demonstrant*innen haben schlicht Angst
um ihre Gesundheit.
Andere glauben an Verschwörungstheorien.
In Impfgegner-Gruppen z.B. auf Facebook vermischt
sich häufig beides - Angst und Desinformation.
Viele Eltern sind dadurch verunsichert. Und
zweifeln an dem Nutzen von Impfungen - der
wissenschaftlich gut belegt ist.
Jakob Maske ist Kinderarzt in Berlin. Er
weiß: Impfstoff schützt zuverlässig.
Dennoch begegnen ihm viele Eltern mit Bedenken.
–  Die Zahl der verunsicherten Eltern nimmt deutlich zu, durch die öffentlichen oder auch vor allem
die sozialen Medien. Wir sehen, dass viele Eltern zweifeln,
ob Impfungen noch gut
sind. Aber durch unsere Aufklärung
erreichen wir eigentlich, dass wir diese skeptischen
Eltern dazu bringen ihre Kinder so zu impfen,
wie es wirklich gut für sie ist.
Es gibt in Deutschland keine Impfpflicht.
Aber: Seit dem 1. März brauchen Kinder für
den Kitabesuch oder Schulbesuch einen Nachweis
- über eine Masernimpfung. Ausgestellt wird
diese meist von Kinderärzten - wie Jakob
Maske.
Der Grund für die Nachweispflicht:
Die Virusinfektion ist extrem ansteckend und
kann zu schwerwiegenden Schäden führen.
In einem von 1000 Fällen endet sie tödlich.
Weltweit starben 2018 140 000 Menschen
an Masern. Wirklich helfen kann nur eine
Impfung.
Allergische Reaktionen hingegen sind nachweislich
extrem selten. Bei 1 000 000 Geimpften treten
sie nur in ein bis vier Fällen auf.
Trotz der sehr eindeutigen Faktenlage sprechen
Impfgegner gern von „Impfwahnsinn und Panikmache“.
Die Weltgesundheitsorganisation erklärte
sie bereits 2019 zur globalen Bedrohung.
Denn: Um das Virus auszurotten, müssen möglichst
viele Menschen geimpft sein. Ungeimpfte sind
eine Bedrohung - auch für ihre Mitmenschen.
Trotzdem gibt es sogar Ärzte, die vor dem
Impfen warnen - und nicht vor den Masern.
– Die Impfstoffe, die erst mal drin sind im
Kind, die kriegt man nicht mehr raus.
Die Ärztin meint, Impfschäden würden vertuscht.
Eine Verschwörungstheorie, die auf dieser
Impfgegner-Demo 2019 gut ankommt.
– Das ist ein wirklicher Angriff auf unsere
Gesundheit. Und wenn dann immer geredet wird
von Herdenimmunität und Herdenschutz. Und
ich sehe aber wie die Herde immer kränker
wird, dann möchte nicht Teil dieser Herde
sein, wirklich nicht.
Eine Impfgegnerin - mit eigener Arztpraxis.
Die Medizinerin redet gerne auf Anti-Impfdemos
- ihre Auftritte verbreiten sich auch auf
Youtube.
Hier wie auch an anderen Orten im Netz gibt
es Ärzte, die sich offen gegen das Impfen
aussprechen.
Zum Beispiel: „Impfen nützt nichts, Impfen
schützt nicht, Impfen schadet“.
In geschlossenen Facebook-Gruppen und impfkritischen
Foren: Tipps, wie Eltern die Impfpflicht am
besten umgehen können.
Wir geben uns selbst als Kritiker aus. Immer
wieder fällt das Stichwort: Impfunfähigkeit.
Eine Arztpraxis gibt online Anleitungen inklusive
Mustertexten, wie man am besten an eine
Impfunfähigkeitsbescheinigung kommt.
Und dann stoßen wir auf einen Arzt, der per
Mail direkt eine Impfunfähigkeitsbescheinigung
anbietet - gegen Geld.
Eigentlich ist die Bescheinigung für sehr
seltene Fälle gedacht, zum Beispiel für
schwer kranke Kinder mit Immunschwächen,
die wirklich nicht geimpft werden dürfen.
Wir machen die Probe und schreiben dem Arzt
unter falschem Namen, erfinden ein Kind namens
Jakob und bitten um die Bescheinigung.
Die zehn Euro packen wir in Alupapier, wie von
Dr. Scheel erbeten. Wir warten, ob unser erfundenes
Kind tatsächlich eine Impfbescheinigung bekommt.
Und fragen derweil den Kinderarzt Jakob Maske,
wie er das Angebot des Kollegen findet.
Schockiert Sie sowas?
–Ich bin absolut schockiert, dass so was
ein Arzt durchführt, absolut schockierend
für mich.
Der Kinderarzt, der per Mail die Bescheinigung
anbietet, macht aus seiner Einstellung keinen
Hehl. Auf einem sogenannten „Impformationskongress“
im April lässt sich Dr. Scheel als unerschrockener
Kämpfer gegen die Impfpflicht feiern.
– Heute freue ich mich ganz besonders auf
den Kinder- und Jugendarzt Dr. Wolfgang Scheel.
Der erklärt online, wie er Eltern hilft,
die Masernimpfung zu umgehen:
– Es kann Sie
niemand, niemand und auch der Papst persönlich
nicht zwingen, ihr Kind impfen zu lassen.
Eine Impfpflicht gibt es nicht, aber es
gibt eben eine Nachweispflicht. Sie können
aber, und dabei helfen wir schon, nachweisen,
dass ihr Kind nicht geimpft werden darf.
Für den Nachweis reicht angeblich die Angabe
einer familiären Vorerkrankung.
Eine Woche später bekommen wir Post von Dr.
Scheel. Die Impfunfähigkeitsbescheinigung
für Jakob – für ein Kind, das es gar nicht
gibt. Der Kinderarzt hat trotzdem ein Attest
geschickt.
Warum macht er das? Wir bitten um ein Interview,
schicken ihm unsere Fragen - keine Antwort.
Auch am Telefon kein Durchkommen. Wir besuchen
ihn in seiner Praxis – auch hier kein Interview.
Stattdessen verweist er hinterher per Mail
auf die vielen Eltern, die sich an ihn wenden,
um so dem „Impfzwang“ zu entgehen. Warum
er Kindern ein ärztliches Attest ausstellt,
die er gar nicht kennt, erklärt er im Juni
2020 auf Nachfrage so:
Ist das nicht illegal? Die Bundesärztekammer
sieht Dr. Scheels Verhalten jedenfalls kritisch.
– Er hat das Kind nie gesehen. Er hat sich
also nie davon überzeugt, dass tatsächlich
eine anerkannte Gegenanzeige für eine Masernimpfung
vorliegt und dann hätte er ein unrichtiges
Zeugnis ausgestellt und das müsste staatsanwaltschaftlich
geprüft werden.
Der Kassenärztlichen Vereinigung ist Dr.
Scheel schon länger als Impfgegner aufgefallen.
Im Februar demonstrieren vor dem Gebäude
Eltern dafür, dass er seine Zulassung als
Kassenarzt behalten darf. Dass der Arzt Impfunfähigkeitsbescheinigungen
ausstellt, ohne Patienten untersucht zu haben,
war hier nicht bekannt.
– Wenn der Arzt das in Einzelfällen und das
gibt es sicher, medizinisch begründbare Einzelfälle,
das tut oder die Kinderärzte das tun, dann
ist das in Ordnung. Wenn das am Fließband
ausgestellt wird und gar noch ohne Untersuchung
oder auch ohne körperlichen Kontakt, dann
ist es sicher schwierig und würde auch verfolgt
werden.
Um das Masernschutzgesetz zu umgehen, schrecken
Impfgegner vor Strafhandlungen nicht zurück
– sie geben in ihren Foren Tipps, wo man
einen Blanco-Impfpass erhält. Wir probieren
es aus - für nur 3,50 Euro bestellen wir einen
leeren Impfpass.
Auch Ärztstempel gibt es online einfach zu
kaufen.
– Selbstverständlich kann man Impfpässe käuflich
erwerben und diese auch selbst ausfüllen.
Das ist allerdings eine Urkundenfälschung
und kann strafrechtlich verfolgt werden.
Besonders fatal sind solche Methoden für
Menschen wie sie: Gabi Schellbach ist Kindergärtnerin
in Kehl, Baden-Württemberg.
117 Kinder betreuen sie in der städtischen
Kindertagesstätte. Wer von ihnen gegen die
Masern geimpft ist und wer nicht, sollen die
Erzieher*innen kontrollieren. Doch die Impfpässe
sind nicht immer vollständig ausgefüllt:
– Teilweise fehlen die Stempel der Ärzte,
teilweise wurden Kreuzchen nachgetragen, wo
wir nicht wissen wer dieses gemacht hat.
Wie also sollen Kindergärten und Schulen
überprüfen, ob die Impfnachweise echt sind
oder nicht? Nachfrage beim Bundesgesundheitsministerium
– dazu gibt es keine Antwort.
Die Verantwortung lastet allein auf ihren
Schultern. Und auch die Sorge, dass die Kleinsten,
die noch zu jung sind für die Impfung, durch
die Masern gefährdet werden. Deswegen möchte
sich Gabi Schellbach wenigstens auf Bescheinigungen
verlassen können, die von Ärzten ausgestellt
sind:
– Also ich vertraue den Ärzten und dann erwarte
ich auch, dass die ehrlich sind und auch ehrliche
Bescheinigungen ausstellen.
Solange sich einige Ärzte daran nicht halten,
bleibt das Risiko, dass Kinder der gefährlichen
Maserninfektion schutzlos ausgeliefert sind.
Was denkt ihr: Sollte der Staat auf Impfungen
bestehen und Nachweise einfordern? Schreibt
es in die Kommentare!